Tyler Trinh: Well.
Rohan Koshy: We were talking about.
Tyler Trinh: Greeting.
Rohan Koshy: You, Jira, update on a ticket which says that I want
Rohan Koshy: this stuff to get done and.
Tyler Trinh: We want this as well.
Rohan Koshy: And rematronic tools.
Tyler Trinh: And basically get it done in 2 weeks. You have one legal.
Rohan Koshy: Right.
Tyler Trinh: Make a task for whatever Ralphon, said.
Tyler Trinh: Jira, can you make a Pbi?
Tyler Trinh: 2 other things like, Can you.
Rohan Koshy: The question.
Tyler Trinh: Here. Can you give me a new.
Rohan Koshy: Sure. Yeah.
Rohan Koshy: Make a task to investigate a new chair at smoke.
Rohan Koshy: Alright. See? You.
Tyler Trinh: You know, we don't actually need.